so you're are you you're still you're
the founder of Annapurna living right
and which is so cool it's a Lifestyle
brand designed to empower women through
mindfulness meditation and devotion
um
how often how much do you work on that
started out kind of mother-centered now
it's not so much it's just really more
woman centered and about like connecting
to yourself and not looking outside of
yourself for the answers and not
thinking like somebody else is going to
like tell you how to live your life that
you have all the answers like just
bringing women back home to like knowing
that they're enough and that that no one
else knows them better than themselves
and that yeah you may need support and
help here and there but ultimately if
that support and help is not helping you
to go back home into your own self then
it's not really helping you know what I
mean so so we um have conversations on
different themes
um I've done this for seven years I used
to I hold a monthly call
um kind of like a circle now I do it
only four times a year but I did it
every month on the full moon for almost
seven years even when I was promoting
the major because like I had all these
women and we would just talk about like
the messiness of life and like listen
and I don't have it figured out I'm not
an expert but I'm sure like into like
exploring and we use poetry we use
writing prompts
um just to connect
because the Life Is Life Is So
distracting and there's so much
um pull from the self and into like all
these different you know labels and like
you did that and arguments and like
sides it's like
we need people who like are connected to
themselves and when you're connected to
yourself you know what you need and you
know how to show up and so that's what I
do and
um yeah it's been a real labor of love
for me um it's made me grow a lot and
making all the videos and stuff
um and holding space I love to hold
space for other people's growth
not because
I know the answer but I know how to hold
space
and I love doing that so
it's um something that I'm not afraid of
I'm not afraid of that